[Musique]
la dernière année et surtout le
confinement ont persuadé israël que son
amoureuse des dernières années était la
femme de sa vie
l'été dernier il lui a fait la grande
demande exprès je m'attendais puis il
m'a quand même surprise qu'achille de
sorte la vague mais ouais c'est ça les
thématiques avec moi ça m'a comme ça les
hommes plusieurs amoureux il n'avait
aucune idée de l'aventuré qui les
attendait mais ont été finalement le
croire qu'elle a qu'à midi c'est un peu
passé on a dit qu'ils avaient la salle
en partageons avec près de 130 personnes
ils ont décidé d'abandonner leur plan
initial et d'organiser leur propre
mariage cet été yohan font ça peut être
compliqué fleurissement ça me prier tu m
entends un autre a trouvé celle que
j'étais puis au final tu ose encore là
c'était comme j'ai tombé sur la bonne
leur fleuriste 7 anaïs d'antan nama mon
atelier les fins de semaine les jeudis
vendredis samedis et pleine fleur la
plupart de ces contrats pour des
mariages ont été reportés son chiffre
d'affaires est passé de 200 mille
dollars à 20 mille dollars l'an dernier
j'ai trouvé ça dur j'ai pleuré kim a
abandonné 10 comme dans toute chose
comme un deuil ammaniti fait j'ai misé
sur le sur le positif puis je suis passé
un été avec mes enfants
puis j'ai retrouvé le bonheur de faire
des fleurs at il juste pour faire des
fleurs et non parce qu'il ya des clients
qui attendent
un résultat global toutes les facettes
de l'industrie du mariage ont dû
s'adapter changer leur approche
on a planifié comment aubin fait qu'est
ce qu'on va faire
emmanuel confection des robes de mariage
sur mesure depuis huit ans elle a dû
réaménager son appartement pour y
travailler
le salon est un serveur avec la révision
en effet avec un nouveau collègue de
travail
son fils de deux ans on prend une pause
ce qui l'a marqué au cours des derniers
mois l' angoisse vécue par les fiancés
j'ai moi j'ai eu énormément de clients
qui pleurent téléphone
je me suis connecté avec une psychologue
d'enfants afin de leur les aider à les
soutenir parce qu'elles étaient contents
d'être plusieurs clients qui qui pleure
de les farc sont vraiment la peine
vivez la déception monde à saleilles
connaît bien les émotions qui habitent
les nouveaux mariés comme notaire elle
officialise des unions depuis plus de 10
ans en mars 2020 on a complètement
arrêté de faire des mariages ici en
septembre dernier elle a complètement
réaménagé sa terrasse personnel pour
être en mesure de célébrer des mariages
on a fait le toit et tout ça pour
prévoir s'il pleut et aussi a laissé
beaucoup d'espacé aération pour que les
fluctuations de l'erc
l'air circule quand même et aucun détail
n'a été laissé au hasard
après pour donner l'ambiance justement
qui peut manquer en raison donc du
nombre réduit de participants dans le
mariage
donc on prévoit ça pour donner un petit
peu de peps de joie
une centaine d'amoureux ont pu célébrer
leur union ici au cours des derniers
mois un événement privé intime que
plusieurs couples s'apprête à vivre
cette année devant l'incertitude quand
j'entre la pandémie les gens qui ont
décidé de maintenir leur mariage cet été
ont décidé de se marier dans la
simplicité dans l'imprévu or vielles à
l'important c'est notre union notre
amour c'est ce que compte faire audrey
et israël un petit mariage avec quelques
invités dans la cour du chalet familial
ça fait deux mois la 4l le 31 juillet
prochain
elle pourra enfin mettre sa robe ici
marie michel lauzon radio canada
montréal